- Like the rest of the
world at this moment,
I'm obsessed with Dua Lipa, all right.
She was, I mean, she's
awesome, so that's why.
She was a battle round adviser
on "The Voice" last season
for Team Kelly as well,
so she has great taste.
Let's start with that.
And she couldn't have been nicer.
It's always nice to like, meet
people you adore musically,
and then they live up to
your expectations as a human
in real life.
But the other day she
had a big announcement.
It was so secret in fact,
she called me before the
audience got into the house seats
at our studio so they
couldn't hear yet either.
And we can finally share
what she had to say.
So check it out.
Hey, what's up, Dua?
How you doing?
Where are you?
- I'm good, I'm in London.
It's nice to see you, how are you?
- I'm good actually, I'm great.
Life is getting so much better, right?
So before I forget though,
thank you so much for helping
Team Kelly on "The Voice."
Did you have fun?
You were so good at it.
- Oh, thank you.
I had so much fun.
It was definitely such a new experience
but it was so cool to
get to learn next to you
and see the way that you mentor everyone.
It was really amazing and
super inspiring, I loved it.
- Oh man.
Well, ditto, you have such
a great energy about you,
you're such a light, it was so fun.
And I love your music so much.
It was just, it was cool to
like, love someone musically
and then you lived up like as a human.
Like, sometimes that
doesn't always happen.